crime policy is under fire again over
these stories shocking video shows a
brazen carjacking in new york where
crooks jumped on top of a minivan
pummeling its 53 year old driver after a
crash the victim was later treated for a
fractured eye socket
and over in oregon critics are lashing
out at governor kate brown for granting
clemency to a cold-blooded murderer and
not bothering to tell the victim's
family that he was back on the streets
brown defending her actions by saying
the killer was only 17 when he committed
the crime all right um on that point
judge when what about the decision to
not charge somebody as an adult or grant
them clemency because of something at
17. you know
first of all kate brown i don't know if
you remember but she's the one uh i
think it was right before thanksgiving
when she said when they decided there
should only be six people for
thanksgiving at your thanksgiving dinner
table and that if your neighbor if you
see that your neighbor has more than six
uh call that call the authorities i mean
now she's a little wacky as far as i'm
concerned there i mean what if you have
seven kids really tell the other ones to
hit the road jason um but but more
importantly more importantly the fact
that this woman would decide
that she would decide to let out a
convicted murderer who was convicted not
just of murder but a murder for hire and
understand there are different levels of
murder a murder for hire a murder to
silence a witness i'm sorry this is
murder to silence a witness those
murders are particularly heinous for
which you can in some states have the
death penalty get the death penalty she
decides without even contacting the
family of the victim uh who was a 17
year old girl who knew about this dirt
bag and he was a dirt bag he had he had
done a a whole spree of burglaries and
she knew about him and he wanted to
silence her and he did it by shooting
her in the back of the head
kate brown is an imbecile uh she doesn't
understand what juries go through before
they convict beyond a reasonable doubt
all of the appellate courts the mid the
mid-level and then the highest level of
appellate courts the judge who makes
this sentence than the corrections and i
think it just erodes of faith in the
criminal justice system it tells victims
families don't come forward don't
testify because they're going to let
them out and it tells the people that
we're soft on crime and you know we ask
them that's one of the hardest things as
a d.a as an assistant d.a is to get
people to cooperate and testify
why should they cooperate if that guy's
going to be out on the street in a
minute you want to comment on this case
yeah sure i'll be quick uh he should
move in with kate brown whatever her
name is what's the name of the
government brown yeah she should take
the guy in look they always mention the
age of the suspect they never ever
mention the age of the victim that
drives me crazy
uh and it does tell everybody when the
sentences are given they could change it
any time they're essentially fluid it's
like i serve a life sentence without
parole for murder but i identify as a
non-violent felon you know why not and
and this is why the florida sheriff we
talked about yesterday was right when he
said hey shoot intruders dead when they
are home invade because that's the only
foolproof 100 prevention of recidivism
oh and if you think they might let him
out you might want to shoot him dead
jessica on the carjacking in new york i
mean the carjackings that's not the
first one this is happening a lot
and on video i remember when eric adams
was giving a press conference on top of
a subway station one of the outdoor ones
and witnessed carjacking right behind
him and actually made the call himself
to report it
what i'm overwhelmed by is the shocking
lack of humanity that is permeating
through every level of society and this
coming off of a time when i felt like we
were united certainly in the early days
of the pandemic where people were scared
were conscious of their elderly
neighbors everyone wanted to protect
those in their life that they needed to
and
it obviously has electoral implications
but those are so small in the context of
just how you treat people when you're
walking down the street
jason you hadn't been in new york in a
while right or at least i know your wife
hadn't like what have you noticed
anything different here and are you is
there like an increased anxiety about
crime yeah that it does not feel the
same safety even in the times square
area that there used to be you could
walk you know all across the city and
but look respect juries and i i think
there's been a great disrespect there
but you've also got to prosecute these
people and if you don't elect
prosecutors that actually prosecute the
people committing the crime there's not
going to be a deterrent
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else